So, here I have two curves, okay, f1 and
f2, and those are meant to be
as taken in two different times.
And, here I'm just looking at
this point, x0, and, just so
you understand, this is the value at,
if you will, time two.
This is the value at time one,
and that's true for all of these.
And the question is,
how much does the curve move?
So, what I have to do is,
I want to find this displacement at x0.
All right, so do it as follows.
So, here's how we do it.
We initialize, since this is iterative,
we have to initialize.
We'll first start by assuming
that our displacement was 0.
That is u and v are all 0's everywhere.
That's great,
that makes the work really, really fast.
I don't do anything,
it's the original picture.
Now I have to estimate the next one,
d1 by figuring out what
the new displacement is.
That's what this new little
delta d is going to be.
So how do I do that?
Well I have to compute
these tangents and
you can see the tangents
are right there, okay?
And what I do is,
based upon that tangent, come down here.
It says oh, okay,
if this thing were actually a plane,
this amount, that's my d hat.
That's the amount I have to displace
over in order to line up these points.
That's assuming this thing were a plane.
If we really were a plane, that would be
the amount that I would have to move.
So let me do that displacement and
I end up there.
So now I've got my d1 which was
just d0 plus my new estimate.
And guess what?
I have to do it again so now I take a
look and say I have to move this amount.
So I add that to my d,
and I move it that much.
And guess what?
I do it again.
Estimate tiny little d hat, this time.
And voila.
It turns out that f1 of x minus d3
is almost exactly f2 at this point.
Okay?
That's the iterative refinement.
And the only thing that
it takes in order to do
this iterative Lukas-Kanade beyond
the regular one is this warping step.
Given some UV that you've
computed between one image and
the next, take that first image,
warp it through that, that flow field.
And now you'll have almost the second
image, and you just apply it over again